voilà bruce willis vous êtes c'est un
comédien vous connaissez évidemment très
bien vous êtes extrêmement bien habitué
à sa voix en français mais qui fait
cette voie est bien le monsieur est là
s'il est là sans me retourner en direct
ils s'appellent patrick poivey bonjour
est ce que vous avez déjà rencontré
bruce willis oui oui oui on fait ce
qu'on pouvait entendre un petit peu
parlé quand allez-vous cela que je vais
très bien comme un matin d'ailleurs avec
la voix du matin chagrin mais sinon ça
va c'est votre vrai voit on voulait
travailler celle de la lèze un peu où
c'est à dire qu'il a l'oeil qui rit
alors fois avoir la voix qui rit un peu
fou une base fourier encore il valait
kirikiri sais pas quoi bah ça frise un
peu quoi bonjour vous allez mieux ça
ouais un fauteuil livre à côté patrick
poivey elle aurait pu être pour nous ce
matin tour à tour kim basinger ou
milanés griffiths on a décidé qu'elle
serait ce matin pour nous de jennifer
aniston voici dorothée gmac les la voix
française entre autres 2 jennifer
aniston bonjour ne sais quel beau
parterre ceux qui gagnent alors deux
cousins bruce willis et tom cruise et en
cause aussi ce we à 80% c'est pas mal
quand même
les a par exemple dit la même nuit 10
est la même en tom cruise alors à la
preuve je nous donne la phrase j'ai
planté des tomates dans mon jardin on
fait un truc sur sept au programme c'est
bien que né aujourd'hui en inde en
planter des tomates plantes et des
jardins ce matin à aller au bout ce
ministre là j'ai planté des tomates ce
matin dans mon jardin 1 1
non mais on dit il du manque et tout est
en temps cruz
je suis un très bon acteur donc j'ai
planté des tomates ce matin dans mon
jardin 1
non mais je suis une meilleur acteur du
monde mais il faut que ça se sache
c'est absolument étonnant alors si si je
vous demande le même exercice dorothée
c'était déjà la même phrase en botola et
en finlande team basinger alors avec les
tomates encore vous allez la phrase que
vous voulez voir mais là je suis dans la
cucaracha nani avec avec le rédacteur en
chef didier regnier voilà pardon tout ça
y est j'ai dansé la cucaracha avec le
rédacteur en chef dudit renier mes deux
compères c'est la voie la demande
jennifer excusez-nous sait on vous
conseille mr froid comme ça ça va pas
être évident mais merci de votre image
semaines déjà
didier regnier alors on ne voulait en g
et danser la cucaracha dans une boîte de
dix avec des iraniens
didier regnier qui va la garder en
souvenir merci pour lui
héhéhé en team en kim basinger
j'ai dansé la cucaracha dans une boîte
de nuit avec didier regnier les 11
janvier et on peut la voir au bény à ce
que bin il a aussi dansé la cucaracha
avec sophie davant on va dire ma
changement obg temps c'est la coupe est
une boîte de nuit avec sophie de penser
car elle
roger cale le padre le pas pour ça comme
ça vous êtes un peu leur père je ne
savais pas dites moi vous avez doublé
vous aussi de grandes stars
hollywoodiennes
oui oui c'est vrai oui c'est vrai c'est
tout et peter sellers est doublé charlie
chaplin sur tout ça c'est donc le dealer
indicateurs non les panthères parce que
vous savez là il y avait un petit
problème selon la maison la production
c'était au oui celle roumois alors vous
même c'est oublier le dernier qu'il a
fait d'ailleurs qui s'appelait mister
jones
vous jouez un personnage très émouvant
et très
et lewis était alors je sais que chez
richard n ces mots qu'il doublait la
partie par exemple pièces qui le
doublait dans la partie moi c'est vous
c'est là qu'il soit très envie de vous
poser
messieurs messieurs madame sait comment
se retrouve donc à avoir comme le
privilège du doublé des gens énorme
comme comme tom cruise comme aniston
comme melanie griffith commence à se
lever les nombreuses sur le sur le
créneau au casting
je ne sais pas si nous sommes nombreux
mais bon on fait des essais puis
maintenant et il faut quoi est-ce qu'il
faut que la voix sa part andré lavoie
français s'apparente à celle d'origine
ou pas forcément c'est pas obligatoire
je crois que c'est plutôt un phénomène
de personnalités qui ceux qui se mettent
l'une à côté de l'autre et qui
fonctionnent les enjeux quoi l'énergie
l'énergie du comédien la même façon de
se défendre dans l'humeur de la
personnalité du comédien souvent ces six
là une grande facilité d'adaptation de
faire ce que l'acteur a fait que pousser
ça parce qu'en faisant et c'est sale
c'est là la grande différence parce que
vous et le comédien évidemment mais et
kadir les sentiments ou la violence ou
la nonchalance de rejouer de retour
attention au moment de la prise pas là
c'est clair c'est de ne pas apporter ce
que vous pourriez donner souvent avec
des mots qui synchrone ne sont pas
obligatoirement dans l'arithmétique
quelque chose comme ça et à ce moment là
c'est un exercice de style qui est qu'il
faut apprendre s'il faut quand on
voulait travailler roger carel on
l'apprend est-ce que c'est frustrant
pour des questions l'ombre et la lumière
r la frustration tout ça ça n'existe pas
parce qu'on fait notre métier
le doublage ce n'est qu'une mine infime
partie de notre métier notre métier
c'est le théâtre
notre métier c'est de tournage vérité
c'est tout le reste c'est la pub c'est
des commentaires de films cd films
animaliers ces put une vie
extraordinaire
ce n'est pas frustrant mais prenons
maintenant eh bien on peut maintenant
être comédien à notre époque c'est jouer
mais c'est très bon l'hydre à je ne sais
combien de temps parce que vous vous
appelle pour faire à peu près tout la
radio comme ils le diront fait
absolument
mais c'est vous êtes au départ comédien
alors ce qui est un petit peu navrant
maintenant c'est que beaucoup de gens
pensent qu'ils vont pouvoir faire du
doublage n'en étant pas comédien et ça
c'est la grosse erreur il brosse et
allemands ont tout de suite puisque vous
avez un petit exercice pour vous trouver
chez vous que c'est pas si facile que ça
et c'est absolument un travail de
comédien alors nous avons la chance que
dorothée vous vous soyez à les
personnages donc des jours et des vies
du feuilleton qui passe avant notre
émission donc voilà ce qui va se passer
on va vous diffuser un petit extrait
donc de du feuilleton en amande
américain dans sa version finale avec la
bande rythmo où ça commence à vous ça
vous met à la loi des écrans partout
autour de nous l iphone est l'on regarde
ce qui se passe à la version originale
qu'il va falloir doubler en plateau
après regarde regarde votre première
remarque on dirait que c'est très
artisanal s'est hissée toujours écrit à
la mairie comme ça oui c'est étonnant
mais on ne peut pas en ce qui me
concerne je pense et ça vous est déjà
arrivé d'avoir une banderille mot écrite
en
voilà c'est impossible une fois cette
façon comme ça en fait eh bien je ne
sais pas je n'arrive pas à comprendre la
saison galère l'as techniquement si je
dois vous expliquer c'est quand un mot a
l'air très allongée très long c'est que
la personne lefebvre aldi et donc la
longueur d'une cela il est comme un
train qui prolonge à la fin d'un mauvais
indice commune que ça veut dire qu'il a
encore la bouche ouverts c'est
l'addition doublé vous vous entraînez
combien de fois parce que j'imagine ça
se fait pas comme ça au pied levé sa
garde et rennes on a ça dépend ça
n'envoie pas d'accuser autrui dans la
difficulté du film déjà wymeersch aux 6
il ya vraiment des grandes productions
on vous fait une projection en langue
originale d'abord qui arrive mais c'est
de plus en plus à celles dont le bien
mais maintenant on enregistre souvent
les grands films on arrive tout seul un
event chacun que la voiture une banque
différente mais autrement on voit le une
fois deux fois ci on pas bien on pourra
les biens qui est rare et nice matin
roger nous aurons qu'une seule fois et
comme le réalisateur et achète d'enquêté
sur le plateau qui dormait beaucoup mais
il était sur le plateau les rôles on va
démarrer avec dorothée donc lexie et
vous rejet voulait que son partenaire
s'est parfois ktm et vous allez rester
là pour que le puce 3g rien dit j'aime
passer comme ça roger à laquelle l'armée
charge bon allez c'est parti je crois
qu'il double alors qu'il ait d'abord ses
côtés non c'est toi j'ai rencontré hop
il est dit que tu paraissais étendue
elle n'avait pas tort avoir ta réaction
non non non je fais très bien l'excès et
des mois la vérité il ya un problème
c'est complètement stupide j'ai pas
tellement peur je te prie pour moi
chérie mais tout va bien donc à quel que
soit le problème nous pourrons
l'affronter ensemble d'accords est
maintenant tu sais quoi tu vas me dire
de quoi il s'agit bon mes enfants je
vais vous dire une chose la nounou fait
[ __ ] jory il n'y a pas ce qu'on
appelle le start c'est quoi ça
géologie d'armes et tu le sais tu le
penses à voilà il ya une place il ya une
barre voyez-vous quand à bord il ya une
part ici et on attaque la barre mais je
suis sa femme change maintenant ça
derrière moi c'est quand l'image change
le projet s'étend à demander une grande
maison
ils ont donné ça donc c'est pas alors
vous avouer 9h à 15h ya tout il ya la
veille à l'intention il dit au bout
d'une ou des cours il veut dernier elle
avait plus que jamais aux bleus c'est
pas moi ça ne va bien ce qui m'épate
c'est qu'ils le disent les textes au
moment où l'oeuf à 16h vous devez lire
autant regarder l'image lui l'a fait
parce qu'on a l'habitude c'est parce
qu'on a l'habitude il continue de
préparer la bouche bée qu'ils ont
l'habitude nous allons essayer là
messieurs amour vous n'avez pas le temps
mais est ce que je vais faire se figer
vous accorder un partenaire de choix
patrick vous allez faire le rôle de et
sophie vous faites la dncd s'il est
absolument non je défile l'est pas du
tout je suis pas là je veux simplement
que très vite et pas ici aller avec ça
alors alors c est le rôle masculin ses
abeilles et des foyers d'accueil ou
alors on peut y aller et sophie davant
c'est la partenaire j'ai rencontré au
lit que tu parais s'étendait n'avait pas
peur à voir ta réaction
non non je vais très bien exc dis moi la
vérité d un problème et fait partie
comme chez tout va bien mon coeur quel
que soit le problème nous pouvons
affronter ensemble maintenant tu sais
quoi
quoi qu'il avait lieu à dire de quoi il
s'agit non c'est pas
c'est à dire certaines choses qu'ils
cautionnent marleau marleau et et son
emprise alcoolique
méfie toi toujours démarre le 11 mai
isaac existant en parfaite santé
mais gégé qu'est ce que c'est que tout
sinon tu attends pas facilement prendre
conscience est bon mais voilà il ya
grâce à des petits traits qui soit
qu'est-ce qui ont excellé
quelquefois c'est tout une ouverture de
plus ou une petite respect à l'homme les
a faits à xabi hayet les deux fois le dh
ou de respiration
on va garder le hamas que leur a été
bien c'était bien c'était mon avis ça il
ya certes infime ils vont vous adorer
c'est ce que deux des fils qui pourrait
atteindre les 4 ans je vois rien
non mais c'est vachement dur mais
comment est ce qu'on a le temps
nabeel temps quand on aurait pu avoir
aussi c'est pas un personnage de
l'accord d'un personnage de dessin animé
qui alors ok moi je te faire écouter
roger carel ouais mais il est quand même
beaucoup beaucoup plus belle est ce que
moi est ce que dans quand on a vu que
vous aviez déjà rencontré bruce willis
tech à l'occasion d'un type personnel et
d'autre part pour des lancements de
films été voir un verre après ils sont
sympas avec vous au charbon cette
monnaie personne moi j'ai jamais
entendue c'est une joie non feinte
chevaleyre sam alors j'aurais bien voulu
je suis pressée un jour parce que
évidemment c'est le samu ses comédiens
ça va arriver alors qu'arras au standard
à ce qu'on réagit bonjour yves bonjour
ce film avait doublé toutes les missions
ça c'est pas vu un pourtant c'est très
très bien oui vous avez posé tout à
l'heure la question de savoir si ça
pouvait les frustrés au vu des appels
que l'on n'a pas du tout parce que
beaucoup de téléspectatrices
principalement préfèrent carrément et
ils les connaissent les doubleurs aux
acteurs c'est le cas par exemple de
céline les frênes des doubleurs surtout
de patrick poivey poivey c'est ça elle
aime plus patrick que les acteurs dont
bruce willis c'est pas beau ça continue
à discuter avec nous parce qu'on n'a pas
patrick la téléspectatrice je veux dire
qu'elle préférait elle vous préférez à
bruce willis
regardez la elle la caméra là bas voilà
ouais ouais alors ça écoutez je vous
remercie ça me touche beaucoup
mais disons que c'est comme monsieur
willis qui est une star qui est génial
et l'original est toujours supérieur à
la ddt au doublage est ce que ça vous à
risque dans la rue on vous dit c'est
marrant vous avez la voix de bruce
willis
oui au restaurant ça donne en général
tiens c'est bizarre mais qu'il a une
voix bizarre
coiffée est-ce que c'est plus facile de
réserver une table au restaurant en
prenant la voix de bruce willis les
couleurs
je vous remercie tous pour cette
émission ces charmantes pour voir votre
cas merci d'être venu nous voir s et es
vraiment très impressionnant de ronan
devoir de vous voir en action damien on
continue avec fred zeitoun
bonjour avec vous ferai dans va évoquer
les stars historique du doublage dont
roger et fait évidemment partie de mon
projet est assez partie patrimoine
national en matière de doublage regardez
c'est pas con doublage ecv dron j'ai
regardé mon espace est la première à des
soldats c'est l'acte de naissance mois
gérer ce type france a envoyé quelques
souvenirs n 8 de l'académie des neuf
avec sa tête j'adorais ce qu'ils ont
fait est là il ya aussi michel roux
micheline dax jacques
alors ce matin on s'est amusé à
inventorier comme ça bien sûr sans
exhaustif les grandes stars du doublage
bas toutes ces voix qui ont fait
l'histoire du doublage on y va tout de
suite
à commencer par la plus célèbre d'entre
elles micheline dax alias bibi condamnée
car elle m'a appelé en me disant ma
grande
on nous propose une série de
marionnettes révolutionnaire on sait
qu'un personnage de grosse [ __ ]
folle de son corps et dont personne ne
veut on a pensé à toi et j'ai dit
d'accord avec sa drôle de woippy qui a
fait le tour du monde
sauf dans les pays du maghreb qui pour
des raisons de religion n'ont pas
accepté de diffuser nuque est chaud à
cause de piggy la [ __ ] puisqu'il
tient qu'aux jeunes alors si le doublage
des moquettes demande une vraie prouesse
vocale
n'allez pas croire pour autant que prêté
sa voix des stars américaines soit deux
tours
ça a été très difficile parce que vous
le saurez quand je suis arrivé mama
premier jour sur le plateau
d'enregistrement
le traducteur
me dis bah écoute
je sais pas ce qui s'est passé mais
les deux acteurs principaux ils ont
déconné sans arrêt dès qu'ils étaient de
trois quarts dos et s'insultent m comme
seuls les injures américaine ça nous on
est des enfants de choeur
à côté edit j'ai pas tout compris je
n'ai pas tout ce qu'ils disent alors si
on t'a pris bon c'est pas que tu es bon
mettait à droite donc que va bien
trouver quelque chose qui correspond à
ce qu'il a l'air de faire sur l'écran ce
qui fait que j'ai eu dix ans comme vous
êtes naturel bâti et free j'ai inventé
la moitié du texte ou à peu près mais
attention l'abus de doublage peut
entraîner parfois certaine confusion
pas bête que vous dites là c'est pas
possible à haute dose
ça peut être un piège que je crois que
le danger pour quelqu'un qui ne ferait
que du doublage c'est le danger de
quelqu'un qui se referme sur une
structure très précises comme d'autres
acteurs peuvent s'enfermer sur une
partie des facettes qu'il passa
donateurs de même sans vouloir exploiter
les autres parce qu'au fond cette
facette la marche et qu'ils s'en
contentent d'accord mais est-ce que vous
avez rencontré des acteurs qui se sont
tellement enfermé dans le doublage que
ce doublage affinée par vampiriser tout
le reste de leur carrière
oui mais c'est plus une époque révolue
ce parce que les acteurs comprend
maintenant sont presque tous des acteurs
en activité autrement ou qui tourne ou
qu'ils font quand même du théâtre
bon on vous demande beaucoup c'est vrai
qu'au bon moment sur la besoin de vous
vous êtes bien souvent sur les plateaux
de doublage n'y a pas de problème mais
c'est vrai que je pense me donne je me
souviens de mon enfance où les gens qui
doublait légaré cooperl sûr comme ça des
gens qui était uniquement consacré à ces
tentes c'est un petit peu tu entends
bien sûr parce que je dis bon c'est
confortable maintenant voilà oui bien
sur mes skis un rôle que vous avez
refusé des rôles que je me souviens pas
non parce qu'on me propose toujours des
choses qui sont à peu près dans dans ce
que je sais faire je n'ai pas dit dans
mes cordes puisqu'il est un terreau à
toutes et à tous et non mais en général
ça colle à peu près ce que je veux faire
je sais faire est-ce que vous pouvez
nous faire le serpent du livre de la
jungle qui ce soir qu'une route ont tous
été pourris mais savez-vous vient est
confiant croit en moi
laisse-moi vélines surtout c'est ce
qu'on peut demander à roger moi mon
enfance et winnie l'ourson
oui avec plaisir ce que vous voudrez si
vous avez un pot de miel
ça m'arrange rypien et ya quoi que
l'apparenté oui attention
ah oui à l'époque poursuit mais oui pour
ça
ça peut pas marcher au maghreb sinon on
avait quelques ton copain aussi pardon
et quelle est la voie vous avez préféré
ans j'ai pas spécialement de préférence
vous savez j'ai des souvenirs surtout
même savait que tout premier mickey
c'est moi qui l'ait doublé mais c'était
50 aurait aimé qu'elle sait pas qui est
doublé le premier tech et la neogeo
c'est viens vous n'étiez pas mais à
l'époque les mois de votre mari we meet
adou bla on vient vous chercher au t1 où
on voulait bien quelqu'un j'en viens
vous dire ce que vous en ferez plaisir
de doubler un personnage ça vous
intéresse oui ça m'intéresse tout
m'intéressait attentes à 25 22 en tout
vous intéresse et l'âme j'ai doublé aux
jo dit peter lorre avec est le premier
que j'ai doublé personnage je crois que
tu en ethiopie avait demandé
expressément que ce soit vous qui prenez
sa voix françaises pour louer les
personnes c'est drôle c'était très
curieux parce qu'à l'époque et premier
de chaplin avait été doublé par un
comédien que j'aimais bien qui
s'appelait jacques du mesnil est un
monsieur comme une voix d'acteurs mais
comme à l'époque où on a besoin
d'acteurs que c'était des voix comme ça
évolue
il m'avait entendu je crois dans un truc
et je vais demander effectivement et
comme il était déjà souffrant il n'a pas
pu venir mais il a envoyé quelqu'un pour
voir si je le faisais bien je me permets
qui sont un peu insolente roger pardon
mais tous talents vous à une allusion
est ce qu'on vous a demandé de doubler
des films un peu sexuelles pendant
graphique à pornographiques nommé
érotique oui vous et fédéraux qui le
retrouver en bas de votre voix après on
discute mais pas rester un plaisir de
vous recevoir en mesure de bruyère vous
nous dire au revoir avec axe qui vous
dira encore avec vous avez un petit chat
après plaisir wepad viable mais c'est un
peu audacieux
[Musique]